Vous pouvez voir ce qu'ils voient et ainsi les contrôler,
mais ce serait mieux que la sensation du toucher
soit directement transmise vers les mains des astronautes.
Vous avez besoin d'un appareil haptique,
une interface haptique qui recrée la sensation du toucher.
Et en utilisant des robogamis, nous pouvons le faire.
Voici l'interface haptique la plus petite au monde :
elle peut recréer la sensation du toucher juste sous vos doigts.
Nous pouvons ainsi déplacer le robogami
par des mouvements microscopiques et macroscopiques.
Et ce faisant, vous pourrez non seulement ressentir
la taille de l'objet,
sa forme et ses lignes,
mais aussi sa rigidité et sa texture.
Cette interface est située juste sous le pouce d'Alex,
et s'il l'utilise avec un casque de réalité virtuelle et des manettes,
alors la réalité virtuelle n'a plus rien de virtuel.
Elle devient une réalité tangible.
Les boules bleue, rouge et noire qu'il regarde
ne sont plus seulement différenciées par la couleur.
La bleue est désormais en caoutchouc, la rouge en mousse, la noire de billard.
C'est aujourd'hui possible.
Laissez-moi vous montrer.
C'est vraiment la première fois qu'on le montre en direct
devant un public, un public nombreux,
alors espérons que cela fonctionne.
Vous avez ici une image d'un atlas d'anatomie
et l'interface haptique du robogami.
Comme tous les autres robots reconfigurables,
il est multi-tâche.
Il va non seulement servir de souris,
mais aussi d'interface haptique.
Alors, par exemple, nous avons un fond blanc vide.
C'est-à-dire qu'il n'y a pas de sensation,
afin d'avoir une interface très flexible.
Maintenant, je l'utilise comme une souris pour s'approcher de la peau,
du bras musclé
pour sentir les biceps,
ou les épaules.
Vous voyez maintenant à quel point il devient rigide.
Explorons un peu plus.
Approchons-nous de la cage thoracique.
Dès que je remonte la cage thoracique
et que je passe entre les muscles intercostaux,
qui sont plus tendres et plus durs,
je peux sentir la différence de raideur.
Croyez-moi sur parole.
Il est maintenant beaucoup plus rigide et renvoie plus de résistance
vers le bout de mes doigts.
Je vous ai fait une démonstration pour des surfaces immobiles.
Et si je devais m'approcher d'un organe en mouvement,
par exemple, d'un cœur qui bat ?
Que ressentirais-je ?
(Applaudissements)
Ce cœur qui bat, c'est peut-être le vôtre.
Cette interface peut se trouver à l'intérieur de votre poche
quand vous achetez en ligne.
Vous pourrez sentir la texture du pull que vous voulez acheter,
comme il est doux,
si c'est vraiment du cachemire ou non,
ou celle du bagel que vous pensez acheter,
comme il est dur ou croustillant.
C'est maintenant possible.
La technologie robotique évolue pour devenir plus personnalisée et adaptable,
afin de s’adapter à nos besoins de tous les jours.
Cette espèce unique de robots reconfigurables
est le point de départ pour créer l'interface invisible et intuitive
qui répondra à nos besoins précis.
Ces robots ne ressembleront plus aux personnages de cinéma.
A la place, ils seront ce que vous voulez qu'ils soient.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)